so yesterday we talked about this New
York Times story that exposed that
Donald Trump's tax returns between 1985
and 1994 a show that Trump lost more
than 1.1 billion dollars during that
ten-year period paying no federal taxes
in eight of those ten years and the
reactions from right-wingers have been
varied and some of them are pretty
interesting one approach from the right
was oh don't focus on the content of the
report don't focus on the substance of
the New York Times story focus on the
fact that the New York Times got this
information about Trump and that they
are bad bad bad for doing it and
somebody needs to be held accountable so
here's one example of that reaction from
the right this is turning point USA
flunkey charlie Kirk tweeting sort of a
perfect prototypical example of concern
trolling he tweeted quote who leaked the
misleading Trump tax information to the
New York Times why did they publish it
why didn't they report the leaker to
authorities section 8 of the taxpayer
Bill of Rights says knowingly disclosing
tax information is punishable by prison
who is responsible for this hit job so
that was one we know we see this all the
time when it comes to any reports based
on leaked information if you like the
leaked information you focus on the
content and not how it was leaked if you
don't like the content of the
information you ignore the content and
you focus only on how did this
information leak to begin with classic
strategy employed more by the right than
the left but the left also sometimes
will employ that strategy a totally
different approach was the approach
taken by Fox & Friends which is to argue
that this New York Times report proves
how fantastic a businessperson Donald
Trump is but they did it in this very
strange word salad sort of format here's
a Brian Kilmeade with his take and again
it I don't know if you want to call it
word confetti or word salad just
struggling to use the English language
to communicate anything of meaning take
a look he's a bold businessman which is
chronicled here there's nothing about
this article that you surprised anybody
they got the Daily News in New York
throughout the last ten years just give
details here's an example
he said pass-through income so for
example there might be an incentive to
go by that building to buy that casino
because I'll take a loss this year in
order on my tax returns because I want
to buy for a rainy day I have the
resources because there was a time that
he was actually building his empire the
inflation information focused year by
year at a time of gathering loss he
bought his partners out at Trump Tower
the Trump Plaza Hotel and Casino he
bought an apartment building in West
Palm Beach for forty three million and
business losses for sixty eight point
seven million for us or at least for me
I can't imagine having that much money
spending that much money and being in
debt for him it makes sense he's buying
now building it up because he had
confidence he knows who the properties
would be worth more the properties began
to build in 86 he bought Indy and excuse
me in 87 he spent twenty nine million on
a yacht the market crashed the next day
so no problem he held on to it
he bought a shuttle operation it didn't
do too well but he held on to it but
when he sell it he takes the loss on his
taxes so for you or I may be buying a
summer home is a big move or maybe even
a trailer but for Donald Trump he says I
got some money but I want to really
expand my empire I want to take chances
that's what he's done to his entire life
as a personality as a host as a business
guess what not all of us win on
everything we bought I think that's how
the matter feels absolutely so then in
comes another one of the genius co-hosts
of Fox and Friends Ainsley Earhardt and
she actually calls all of this extremely
impressive she's impressed that Trump
was able to lose more than 1.1 billion
dollars it is an interesting look though
at how New York City real estate
developers work in the 80s and the
nothing you read The Sitter like wow
it's pretty impressive all the things
that he's done in his life I don't know
that there's any suggestion that he
broke the law yeah I think the
suggestion is simply that he used the
tax law as to its benefit yeah that's
the takeaway Steve Doocy
and Ainsley Earhardt just so impressed
by Donald Trump in every way and
unfortunately I hate to say it because
I'm always newly depressed
by the lack of limits to the ignorance
that people will fall for in this
country a lot of people are falling for
for this and I want to clarify before we
go any further Trump is a terrible
president because his policies policies
are a disaster right Trump's not a
terrible president because he lost money
in the 80s and 90s whether he made money
or lost money in the 80s and 90s our
analysis of his policy today would be
the same right it's a disaster the
reason that this actually matters is
that Trump's sole credential for even
running for president from the beginning
is that he knows how to run businesses
that his businesses are successful and
that he would run the country the way
that he runs his businesses so that's
why when people say Oh Trump losing a
billion was a strategy we have to pick
it apart because it's actually the basis
for Trump being president that so many
of his followers actually cite and lean
on now let's break it apart it is true
that sometimes wealthy people or
businesses will show or create losses on
purpose for strategic tax purposes it's
also possible that Donald Trump did this
during some years for which we have not
seen his taxes the New York Times
article that we've been reporting on
this week doesn't show that Trump lost
amounts of money that go way beyond what
would be logical with the idea that
Donald Trump is trying to deliberately
limit the amount of tax that he pays you
in when you do that you try to keep your
losses sort of in line with the gains
that you're trying to offset what Donald
Trump lost in these years in most of
those years between 1985 and 1994 goes
way beyond what you would do as a
strategy to reduce or to try to zero out
your tax liability there is no reason to
go hundreds of millions of dollars
beyond the most advantageous amount for
reducing taxes other than you genuinely
and honestly lost money and
unfortunately you've got people like
Charlie Kirk and the three clowns on Fox
and Friends who are just
good enough at changing the narrative in
part 2 how did this leak and in part 2
Trump is really smart for doing this and
we should actually be impressed by him
that the narrative of Trump is good for
the country because he's good at
business continues to spread and
perpetuate itself like a virus which is
quite frankly what it is we've got to
pick it apart
not because Trump's policy is good or
bad based on whether he lost money in
1987 but we've got to pick it apart
because this is his only credential this
is the credential that his supporters
claim is the reason why he deserved to
be elected president and that one
credential immediately crumbles like a
very poorly built structure as soon as
you analyze it with even the the most
minut critical critical analysis